SARA: A child in any given moment just needs to be loved
and when nobody else is there
to provide it, someone has to.
And it doesn't matter who it is or how it is, they
should be able to have the love that they deserve.
I have always wanted to be a foster parent as
long as I can remember, from probably about 12
years old on, and my joy and my passion
is children.
Ah you do match with me!
So for me, it just made sense to take
care of children in the community in that way.
NICK: You know, initially, shewanted
lots of kids and I wanted one. [laughs]
Little did I know then, like, I couldn't
fathom that it would grow to what it is now.
I don't think that I ever went out
looking to have a multi-racial family,
but I don't think that kids growing
up in a multi-racial household look
at their brothers or sisters as anything
different than their brothers or sisters.
NAOMI: The Multiethnic Placement Act bars child welfare
agencies, adoption agencies from discriminating
on the basis of race or ethnicity in placing
kids for foster care or adoption.
The idea was: Kids should not languish in foster care
when there are loving, safe homes out there for them.
And what you had was a situation where there
were a lot of black children in the foster care
system and caseworkers, lawyers, judges were not
placing those black kids in  thoseloving, safe homes
because their skin colordid not
match the skin color of the parents
willing to take them in. And so a group of
bipartisan people in congress got together
and said "This is crazy. What these children need
are families, and it doesn't matter whether they're
white families or black families or hispanic
families. What they need is a loving, safe home."
Unfortunately, the Multiethnic Placement
Act is becoming increasingly unpopular,
and I am just amazed at the way these activists
from outside the system are using the foster care
system to advance an agenda of
social justice thathas absolutely
nothing to do with the needs of these children.
NICK: Astrid, go eat your breakfast.
LILA ASTRID: Okay.
NAOMI: So, Sarah and Nick Pendleton have adopted four children. Two of the children that they adopted
were African-American, and I cannot figure out why
we would care what Nick and Sarah's skincolor is
when it comes to their ability to care for these children.
SARA: I had just had this dream, just about a little girl with
beautiful brown skin and heart problems, and when the worker called, she said "I have a girl."
It was like, "boom." I knew she was my girl,
and she was like, "Well, i need to tell youabout her."
And I was like, "Okay." And she said "She'sreally sick
and she's got some heart defects." And
the nurse came in and laid a long list of all thethings
wrong with her on the table, and they wereall
looking at me like, "Okay you're gonna walk outtoo,"
because so many people had turned down this child.
NICK:  Even with a medical background, I wasn't
anticipating the level of care that she would
need, but I think over time, our family just kind of
evolved into a family that can handle those
different things when they come up.
NAOMI: She was such a part of their family. Even though
they knew that her situation was terminal,
she would go in a wagon places with them; the other kids
would get into bed with her and, like, talk to her.
So, Ainsley was seven when she finally died.
She had been to Disney World and Lincoln Center;
she had been caving... All of these things that they did as
a family together to cementtheir relationship with her,
and it is the kindof life that
any child deserves, and especially
a child who has been through this kind of trauma.
SARA: As the mom to two black children, I see their race,
but I see them more than any skin
color, hair color, hair type... I see them.
It's heartbreaking to imagine that either of
those girls would still be without a family.
NICK: Astrid does not have any thought about the fact
that she's living with white parents, but she does
know that she's loved, and she has permanency here,
and she knows nobody's taking her away from here.
One day, will she ask me about race? "Why am I...
do I have dark skin and you have white skin?"
Sure, she's gonna ask me about that, but the
one thing she will not ever have to wonder is,
"Is somebody gonna come take me tonight and
move me somewhere else?" She'll never have that
question, because what it comes down to at the end
of the day is that she's loved and she has a place.
NAOMI: I think what the Pendletons
have provided to their children
is so vital, and I think all the time about
how we can find more families like them.
And what I see is a system that
is working to push that away;
a system that is working to say to Nick, "You're a
racist because you think skin color doesn't matter."
I think that's the opposite of where we need to
be as a country, and I look at the Pendletons, and
I think they should be leading us in terms of what
we're looking for in foster and adoptive families.
And whatever Nick Pendleton has to say is so much
more important and so much more true than the
nonsense that is being spouted by these activists
who don't even understand what these children need.
SARA: Every child deserves the same as thenext.
Period. End of story. And whatever ittakes
to give every child a family; to give
every child an advocate who thinks they hung
the moon and the stars... Whether they're going
to live, whether they're going to die, whether
they can read or write, whether they can walk,
whether they're even going to blink their eyes
one time on this entire earth, whether they live
for one week or the rest of their parent's life...
Every child deserves to have someone who
thinks that they are the greatest on this earth.